we all know the global warming is
perhaps the biggest threat facing
humanity over the next 50 years but it's
not all bad news according to Yahoo
according to a recent study rising
temperatures will actually be good for
getting folks in North Dakota out of the
house you never even thought about that
part of it you never even thought about
it
you just selfish underwater Hawaiians
it's not all about you all the time real
horses soda yeah some people global
warming is a good thing there are at
least 40 meth-addicted frakkers and a
dozen or so Buffalo veterinarians who
stand to benefit from it being a little
nicer outside for once so maybe open
your skin mind and think of some of the
benefits of global warning I mean sure
sure the mosquito population will
skyrocket and give most of the southern
hemisphere super Ebola but for a lucky
few looking to sit on their porch on a
balmy February night in North Dakota and
get irradiated by the sunset with their
pet polar bear who now will look like
this and great I say fun that's what I
look like when you shave them every
polar bear polar bears look all scary
but underneath just a little wiener just
so comedians I've listed a couple but
I'm sure there are a lot more ways to
approach this very optimistically what
are some other benefits of global
warming or Lin I'm sorry Annie mesh
Donald Trump will spend his winters in
swamp Marlowe yes please
very good well if it's hot as falls we
know nudist colonies that can't be met
all right um it'll only take 15 minutes
to fly from coast-to-coast Chris yes
yeah